[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 78 de votre émission
avec de l'actualité des idées de sorties
pour bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines voici le programme de ce 19
novembre
focus sur les kids allowed ces ateliers
scientifiques sont proposés aux élèves
de cm1 et cm2 de l'école le cours de la
boussole de mantes-la-jolie
établissements du réseau espérance
banlieue au programme ce matin l'attesté
la présence de vitamine c dans les
fruits et légumes c'est l'une des
informations à retenir cette semaine
l'état officiellement suspendu la vente
du domaine de grignon au promoteur
altarea cogedim une nouvelle procédure
de cession devrait être lancée au second
semestre 2022 première victoire pour les
défenseurs du site qui porte un projet
alternatif
mathieu baron délégué général de grignan
2000 est notre invité et puis comme
chaque vendredi notre sélection idées de
sorties dans le département c'est dans
la deuxième partie de cette émission
avec bien sûr en plateau pour
m'accompagner bixente marc censi
stéphane roux jean michel et ribéry
quels sont les suggestions du jour
bixente parade
du salon histoire de lire et aussi
également de gastronomie du côté de la
région robot liten est resté avec nous
ce sera tout à l'heure dans le sais tu
ce week-end
depuis cette semaine l'école du cours de
la boussole de mantes-la-jolie enseigne
la science à ses élèves grâce aux
ateliers kids lab un enseignement
destiné aux classes de cm1 et cm2 cet
établissement du réseau espérance
banlieue peut bénéficier de ce
dispositif et grâce au partenariat avec
la multinationale basf spécialisée dans
la chimie le reportage de nicolas landry
des élèves de cm1 transformer en
scientifiques en herbe le programme de
la matinée pour cette classe de l'école
du court la boussole de mantes-la-jolie
une expérience pour tester la présence
de vitamine c dans des fruits et des
légumes si on voit que l'homme que
l'équipe etc il sait plus foncée poker
il ya de la vitamine c le légume qui
contient le plus de vitamine c c'est le
poivron et c'est lui qui en contient le
moins c'est donc eu rajhi le concombre
et pour le fruit l'ain j'ai trouvé ça
mieux que de faire un cours de sion sur
ordi ses activités pédagogiques
s'inscrivent dans le cadre du kids lab
une initiative lancée par le groupe
internationale de la chimie basf
aujourd'hui c'est le lancement dans
l'école du court la boussole du réseau
espérance banlieue à travers le thème de
l'alimentation ça un programme qui est
interdisciplinaire vous allez parler du
vocabulaire scientifique du matériel de
l'alimentation quand vous avez de la
science vous avez du français vous avez
aussi des maths puisqu'il est une notion
de quantité en l'initiant à la démarche
scientifique
on lui permet d'apprendre à essayer
corrigé argumenté faire des hypothèses
comprendre les résultats et en tirer une
abstraction des jeunes qui s'intéressent
à la science qui s'intéresse aux modèles
scientifiques qui s'intéressent à la
chimie et qui plus tard deviendront
peut-être effectivement ingénieur chez
basf ou d'odeur d'autres sociétés c'est
vraiment le c'est aussi un des objectifs
le court la boussole c'est 60 enfants
répartis dans six classes allant de la
moyenne et grande section de maternelle
au cm2 une école située au coeur du
quartier du val fourré les quartiers
populaires
connaissent des difficultés sociales
fortes et
en particulier lié à l'insuffisance du
niveau éducatif aux difficultés que les
papas mamans rencontre à accompagner
leurs enfants dans le système scolaire
et c'est pourquoi des innovations comme
celle d'espérance banlieue sont
extrêmement intéressants
l'établissement de mantes la jolie est
ouvert depuis 2015 elle a accueilli plus
de 200 élèves depuis son lancement
la procédure avait fait grand bruit en
plein été suscité de vives oppositions
la vente du domaine de grignon à un
promoteur immobilier altarea cogedim
cette semaine la préfecture des yvelines
a confirmé le rétropédalage de l'état
session stopper processus reporté au
second semestre de l'année prochaine on
en parle avec mon invité par
visioconférence mathieu baron bonjour
bonjour délégué général de grignon en
2000 vous portez avec la communauté de
communes coeur d'yveline un projet
alternatif grignon en 2026 dont on aura
l occasion de discuter tout à l'heure
alors pour les téléspectateurs qui ne
connaissent pas le domaine de grignon
c'est un berceau historique de
l'agronomie française que les étudiants
d'agroparistech vont quitter pour
rejoindre le plateau de saclay à la
rentrée de septembre 2022 c'est un
domaine de 310 hectares avec un château
du xviie siècle des terres agricoles une
forêt c'est une première victoire pour
vous cette annulation vous avez été
entendu
tout d'abord c'est un soulagement parce
que c'était le choix d'altarea cogedim
pour nous c'était le pire des scénarios
est effectivement c'est une victoire que
l'état aurait pu signer avec à
l'intérieur donc pour nous c'est une
décision qui va dans le bon sens et
c'est le moment de se remobiliser avec
toute la communauté des agro des anciens
élèves mais aussi avec tous les élus
locaux qui nous ont soutenus et les
étudiants pour essayer de trouver un
nouveau projet pour ce site grandiose on
rappelle très rapidement ce que
prévoyait ce projet d'altarea cogedim à
qui l'état avait accordé cette vente qui
est bien prévoyez sur place un programme
résidentiel adapté avec de nouvelles con
truction et une programmation sites
touristiques responsable pourquoi ce
projet vous inquiétez
le problème en fait c'était le
démantèlement du site c'est à dire que
al tajer faisait son métier de promoteur
on n'a rien contre les promoteurs mais
il achetait le foncier il le y vendait
les différents bâtiments à différents
acteurs ça pouvait être les bois et les
terres agricoles au département le
laboratoire à la région le faire des
logements dans des dans des bâtiments
historiques et le problème c'est quand
on met des gens qui ont des intérêts
différents c'est très difficile ensuite
de conserver l'unité du domaine et pour
nous c'était une de nos lignes rouges et
c'était très important de conserver
cette unité est de conserver
cette beauté
alors pour justifier cette décision de
reporter cette vente le ministre de
l'agriculture julien de normandie qui
est d'ailleurs un ancien d'agroparistech
a dit dans un tweet tenir compte du
temps de concertation s'accorder aussi
sur le meilleur projet qu'est-ce qui a
fait pencher la balance selon vous il ya
une nombreuses mobilisations 1 depuis
l'annnonce de cette vente cet été
également de nombreux soutiens on pense
forcément à des élus comme gérard
larcher le président du sénat qui est
bien on a porté aussi leur pierre à
l'édifice y aussi des recours qui ont
été déposés sur la légalité justement de
ce procédé qu'est-ce qui a fait pencher
la balance
alors c'est une conjonction de facteurs
mais ce qui se pense que c'est la
mobilisation collective c'est vraiment
une victoire collective avec d'une part
la mobilisation des élus qui ne
comprenait pas pourquoi l'état ne
l'avait pas sollicitée avant de lancer
7.7 consultations en vue de la cession
du domaine donc c'était quand même un
peu gros pour la commune de tivaouane
craignant de se retrouver avec un un
programme avec plusieurs ressentez une
centaine de logements est plusieurs à la
fin de plusieurs centaines de personnes
qui se retrouvaient le genre au coeur du
domaine ca aurai
agrandi considérablement la taille de la
commune de l'autre c'est
l'heureux
l'incompréhension et surtout de choisir
un projet immobilier alors qu'un projet
concernant la transition écologique et
qui souhaitent mettre autour de la table
tous les acteurs de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation de l'environnement pour
réfléchir à la culture de demain on
comprend pas pourquoi l'état n'avait pas
vu l'opportunité d'un tel projet alors
que le giec a récemment
alerté sur les risques qui pèsent sur
notre production alimentaire
vous et votre association je le disais
grignon en 2000 porté avec la communauté
de communes coeur divine ans qu'un
projet alternatif qui n'avait pas été
retenu dans un premier temps par l'état
ces grillons 2026 autrement dit
proposées sur place un centre
international de l'agronomie et de
l'alimentation ça ressemblerait à quoi
ce projet donc l'idée c'est de mettre
autour de la table tous les acteurs de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation de
l'environnement d'offrir en quelque
sorte une arène pour débattre des grands
sujets qui concernent nos systèmes
agricoles on les connaît lui une part le
réchauffement climatique de l'autre
l'érosion de la biodiversité l'érosion
des sols
cd des sujets qui sont déjà traités par
la communauté des chercheurs mais l'idée
c'était comment accélérer la diffusion
des connaissances scientifiques pour
essayer d'établir des nouveaux modes de
production et élaborer des consensus qui
permettent de continuer à nourrir en
concrètement plus concrètement sur le
sur le plan économique l'idée c'était
2-2 d'allier différentes
activités économiques d'une part après
de recherche et d'innovation
bien entendu j'ai une activité
événementielle pour
pour rendre compte de ses travaux de
recherche notamment dans le château avec
des grands séminaires des congrès
l'autre l'autre aspect c'était d'ouvrir
le domaine à l'ensemble des habitants du
territoire pour nous c'était pour ça
qu'on s'était allié avec la communauté
de communes c'est qu'on souhaitait
rendre grignon aux habitants de la
communauté de communes pour qu'ils
puissent profiter du parc qui avait été
fermé suite à la tempête de 99
l'idée enfin c'était de mettre un
parcours de musées une cité de la
connaissance pour former les gens sur
les enjeux de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation de l'environnement
rapidement maintenant le l'important
pour vous ça va être de se remettre
autour de la table de retravailler sur
ce projet pour de nouveau le présenter
lorsqu'il y aura le nouveau processus de
vente exactement le but c'est de
l'enrichir avec notamment avec des
dimensions d'enseignement et de
recherche qui n'avaient pas pu être
développés du fait de la de la position
de l'ags de l'école qui avec les
vendeurs ils ne pouvaient pas se
positionner nous aujourd'hui on va on va
continuer à mobiliser le réseau essayer
de proposer le meilleur projet qui soit
le plus consensuel possible et qui
permettent avec les élus locaux avec la
communauté agroparistech et avec
l'ensemble des des habitants de trouver
le meilleur contrat de cinq ans d sur le
meilleur projet possible pour le futur
de ce site avec des entendu l'ambition
de conserver son unité merci mathieu
baron d'avoir été avec nous
léguer générale de l'association grignon
2000 voilà pour cette information vous
l'avez compris l'une des principales
dans cette semaine du 15 au 19 novembre
mais il y en a eu d'autres on vous
résume ce qu'il faut retenir le tout en
78 secondes et c'est avec mélanie poké
et justine rasé
une table ronde pour conclure une
semaine de sensibilisation à la liberté
d'expression ce 15 novembre trois
réfugiés politiques participer à
l'événement organisé à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines marlène
schiappa étaient présents à
vélizy-villacoublay la ministre délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté répondait à
l'invitation de jean noël barrot député
de la 2e circonscription une centaine de
personnes étaient présentes
la campagne pour le congrès les
républicains continuent après xavier
bertrand c'est valérie pécresse qui
tenait un meeting une étape à domicile
pour l'actuel président de la région ile
de france la ville de la verrière de
faciliter la concertation avec les
habitants sur l'avenir du bois de
l'étang aile inauguré le 16 novembre une
maison de projets les habitants sont
invités à partager leurs habits depuis
le mois d'octobre pour pallier la
désertification médicale de la commune à
la ville de plaisir a fait le choix
d'installer une borne à la maison des
familles flora tristan pour permettre
des téléconsultations la semaine
européenne pour l'emploi des personnes
handicapées se tient jusqu'au 21
novembre une catégorie fortement touché
ces deux fois supérieure au reste de la
population et puis le 18 novembre
c'était la journée nationale de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire la team
anti-harcèlement du lycée bat caen à
rambouillet a organisé plusieurs
rendez-vous pour sensibiliser
[Musique]
1 et vous l'entendiez c'était la semaine
pour l'emploi des personnes handicapées
une semaine européenne à cette occasion
bouygues construction ont organisé un
marché noël ce jeudi sur son siège le
site challenger à guyancourt un
événement animé par quatre et that
établissement et service d'aidé par le
travail ainsi que par l'association les
bouchons de l'espoir le groupe s'est
joint aussi à l'opération bio day un
collaborateur a accueilli le temps d'une
journée un demandeur d'emploi en
situation de handicap ce vendredi les
animateurs périscolaire étaient
également en grève mobilisation
nationale à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats pour de meilleurs salaires et
conditions de travail mouvement suivi
par les animateurs de la commune de
montigny le bretonneux qui se sont
rassemblés devant l'hôtel de ville ce
vendredi matin votre rubrique légal
checking à présent pour vérifier ce que
disent les acteurs de l'actualité
vincent couronne du collectif des
surligneurs décrypte aujourd'hui une
proposition du candidat de la france un
soumise à la présidentielle jean-luc
mélenchon
regardez
s'il est élu jean-luc mélenchon dit ne
plus vouloir appliquer les directives
européennes qui serait contraire à son
programme ces dernières années les
surligneurs ont dû rappeler des dizaines
de fois que le droit de l'union
européenne devaient être respectées car
il prime sur le droit interne ce que
même nos juridictions reconnaissent oui
monsieur mélenchon et tant d'autres
candidats si vous êtes élu vous
n'appliqueraient pas les directives
européennes qui vous gêne c'est possible
mais alors vous voudrez bien répondre à
quelques unes de nos humbles question
êtes vous prêt à payer sur le dos du
contribuable les pénalités financières
auxquelles la cour de justice de l'union
européenne condamnera la france chaque
fois qu'elle ne respectera pas une
directive la france a déjà été condamnée
par la cour de justice pour ne pas avoir
suffisamment lutter contre la surpêche
c'était en 2005 et la cour de justice
condamne à la france à une astreinte de
60 millions d'euros par semestre de
retard êtes vous prêts
monsieur mélenchon si vous ne souhaitez
pas appliquer une directive à la re
négocier avec les autres états membres
pour la conformer à votre programme
électoral etes-vous prêts monsieur
mélenchon à négocier des dérogations au
droit de l'union européenne pour la
france c'est une autre solution mais
alors toutes les autres états
revendiqueront le bénéfice de ces
dérogations et nous ne tireront aucun
bénéfice de notre propre exception libre
à vous aussi mais il faut le dire enfin
êtes vous prêt à museler le juge interne
un français qui condamnerait
systématiquement la france a indemnisé
en cas de non respect du droit de
l'union il faudra pour cela violé la
constitution ou la réviser et donc violé
le droit de l'union le droit l'union
européenne ça se respecte ou alors ça se
négocie ou alors ça se quitte il faut le
dire clairement et ne pas prendre les
lecteurs pour quelqu'un qui ne comprend
pas ce qu'on lui dit
allez c'est l'heure de sortir à présent
dans ce set eu ce week-end
avec bien entendu la sélection de
bixente mais rien senti steban pour
commencer bixente un événement fort de
l'automne qui revient en présentiel
c'est le salon histoire de lire à
versailles exactement grégory pendant
deux jours de nombreux écrivains seront
au rendez vous pour des séances
dédicaces des échances des tables rondes
ces samedi 20 et dimanche 21 novembre de
14h à 18h30 dans un cadre plutôt
sympathique puisque l'hôtel de ville et
de versailles et l'hôtel de la
préfecture et du département des
yvelines ouvrent leurs portes pour
l'occasion nous recevons pour nous en
parler via les malins commissaire du
salon bonjour bonjour monsieur malin le
programme est chargé comme je disais
avec des journées séquencé par demi
heure toutes les 30 minutes de nouveaux
rendez-vous commence on a des grands
débats historiques sur notamment
napoléon j'ai noté pour son bicentenaire
henri iv l'histoire de france en général
l'idée c'est vraiment de laisser la
place aux auteurs pour leur permettre un
échange avec leurs lecteurs et les fans
tout à fait cette rencontre littéraire
c'est l'occasion effectivement de voir
en vrai des auteurs et pas simplement un
nom sur une couverture de livre donc ils
sont facilement approchable on peut
discuter à chacune des tables voilà on a
aussi ce que vous appelez le café des
auteurs des débats des conversations
entre auteurs et et parole libre c'est
ça comment ça se passe donc des grands
débats dans un grand espace de 350
places et puis des moments plus intimes
effectivement quel café le café d'auteur
ou là on s'assoit autour d'un auteur et
on peut lui poser des questions voilà
oui on vous avez vous lu voulu favoriser
aussi ces échanges entre auteurs entre
eux mêmes tout à fait beaucoup de
beaucoup de débats des grands débats des
regards croisés c'est il ya 74 moment de
rencontre
les deux après midi vous on va pas
pouvoir parler de tout les auteurs
présents puisqu'ils y en a je sais pas
combien il y en a
180 11 et si vous me demandez qui sont
les vedettes
bien compliqué c'est une question et
chante donc pardon pardon pour tous les
autres que je ne veux pas nommer non je
pense vous citiez henri iv effectivement
on aura jean christian petitfils avait
plus grands historiens français avec une
très belle biographie on aura la
secrétaire perpétuel de l'académie
française hélène carrère d'encausse qui
va nous parler d'une figure du féminisme
du début du xxème siècle alexandra
kollontaï voilà donc sonné on est
heureux de recevoir bien sûr gnkar
d'encausse
voilà on aura françois kersaudy qui va
nous parler de ker scène vous savez ce
ce médecin ma soeur de himmler qui a
sauvé sans doute plus de cent mille
personnes juifs voilà donc beaucoup
beaucoup de vedettes seront là justement
à propos d'une des personnes d'un des
auteurs veulent être présents il ya
timothée de fombelle on a pu échanger
avec lui c'est notre interview express
[Musique]
alma c'est le une trilogie enfin c'est
les deux premier volume d'une trilogie
dont le deuxième tome vient de paraître
un roman d'aventuré un roman qui
témoigne aussi de ces années
tragiques qui ont été ces trois ou
quatre cents ans de la traite des
esclaves
[Musique]
il se trouve que ce deuxième volume
se termine c'est et dernier chapitre se
passe autour de versailles du château
c'est un moment clé de mon histoire donc
ça a tellement de sens à la fois ce lieu
en particulier et puis ce festival où on
parle d'histoire
[Musique]
on a très envie toujours de rencontrer
ses lecteurs parce qu'il ya eu dans le
métier d'auteur une un côté solitaire
et donc il y avait effectivement une
grande joie à se retrouver devant ses
lecteurs pouvoir les rencontrer à voir
le retour de ce qui est
fait dans cette solitude de l'écriture
donc merci à timothée de fombelle pour
son le deuxième tome de sa trilogie alma
on parlait d'autre tête d'affiche il ya
aussi des comédiens puisque bruno solo
et là cette année il présente dès ce
vendredi le prix du meilleur youtuber
d'histoire c'est important aussi de
parler aux jeunes dans un salon
absolument vous avez raison d'insister
pour cela et donc il ya un phénomène sûr
sur youtube et donc on a décidé il ya
quatre ans de faire un prix du meilleur
youtuber d'histoire elle cette année on
avait cinquante six candidats 56
vidéaste qui publie régulièrement et
bruno solo sera le président du jury
pour remettre le grand prix cette année
et pour terminer il ya une nouveauté
cette année ses histoires en scène des
récits d'histoires jouée par les
comédiens du coup bruno solo participent
mais il ya aussi philippe torreton et
francis huster est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus rapidement alors vous
avez raison d'abord c'est dans un
nouveau lieu donc à l'hôtel du baril à
la chambre de commerce corlieu ces
histoires en scène donc ce sont des
comédiens passionnés d'histoire qu'on
écrit un livre mais je leur demande de
ne pas être que des auteurs mais aussi
être d'être comédien lots qu'ils vont
déclamer les plus beaux morceaux de
leurs de leur livre francis huster va
nous parler de molière par exemple on
parlait de bruno solo donc dans son
livre les visiteurs d'histoire il y là
ils inventent l'idée de dîner avec des
personnages mal connue de l'histoire
c'est cette truculence et on va beaucoup
s'amuser nickel merci beaucoup viennent
et malin d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle vous êtes commissaire du salon
histoire de lire de versailles qui se
tient à l'hôtel de la préfecture et des
départements mais également à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles et dans d'autres
lieux aussi commander on évoquait la
chambre de commerce samedi et dimanche
de 14h à 18h30 merci au comité une
petite question d'ordre pratique on peut
venir sans réserve et où on vient
directement sur place c'est gratuit
c'est ouvert à tous tout le programme
est sur histoire de lire point fr il
faut simplement impasse sanitaires merci
à vous d'avoir été avec nous alors il
est peut-être un peu tôt pour passer à
table bixente mais vous voulez nous
parler de quelque chose en rapport avec
l'alimentation juste je savais quand on
a un gros manque au mans il n'y a pas
d'heure des dégustations et animations
sont proposées par une trentaine de
restaurants sur rambouillet territoire
ça s'appelle gastronomie d'automne voici
une petite découverte de cet événement
en novembre les saveurs d'automne
prennent place dans les assiettes de ce
restaurant de gaz rend cet établissement
participe à la semaine gastronomie
d'automne de rambouillet territoire
myriam bourgeois la directrice et le
chef sébastien bourgeois sont les
parrains de cette 24e édition et cette
année encore ils font découvrir leurs
recettes automnale on propose donc les
pâtés en croûte de chevreuil aux cèpes
aux trompettes de la mort au pied de
mouton ça dépend là pour les fêtes on
passera sur la truffe ont fait évoluer
on aura également le lièvre à la royale
ça c'est un simple afa également de la
maison ont fait depuis depuis toujours
donc un lièvre qui entièrement désossé
qui est qui est farcie la force et
réalise avec du foie gras de la truffe
d'eric vos desserts si les feuilles
deviennent oranges en ce moment cette
chocolaterie porte cette couleur toute
l'année si tu as oublié cette boutique
gourmande va proposer des dégustations
et des animations découvertes autour du
chocolat on commença à parler des
marrons glacés des pâtisseries à base de
marrons justement ce côté un petit peu
automne et on vous propose également des
animations qui se font en fait sur le
point de vente mais l étage pour
expliquer en fait d'où vient le chocolat
la torréfaction des fèves de cacao pour
faire notre chocolat la découverte
automnale de la gastronomie du
rambolitains se poursuit aux
essarts-le-roi cette biscuiterie
participa gastronomie d'automne depuis
2016 pour faire découvrir ses délices
nous allons leur proposer une
dégustation des 15 recettes
pendant cette semaine là avec le rocher
amandes enrobées de chocolat comme comme
une truelle ou alors des notes de notre
caramel caramel beurre salé le rocher au
caramel beurre salé ou le florentin au
caramel beurre salé organisé par
rambouillet territoire gastronomie
d'automne se conclura le dimanche 28
novembre avec le marché de la
gastronomie et de l'artisanat à
rambouillet
ça donne faim bixente donc on rappelle
24e édition l'événement gastronomie
d'automne et se déroule du 20 au 28
novembre sur le territoire de
rambouillet territoire un ce territoire
du sud yvelines en parlant de
restauration quelle est la suite de
votre menu du jour michel therrien à gré
du côté de saint quentin en yvelines
l'élu 10 days reviennent sur la carte
donc des jeux de société réalité
virtuelle jeux vidéo jeux de rôle ou
encore escape game une semaine pour
s'amuser entre amis ou en famille comme
d'habitude grégory je vais vous donner
de petits coups de coeur perso dès ce
samedi il ya un loup garou organisée à
la médiathèque du le canal de monti le
bretonneux 4 cession prévue de 15 heures
à 17 heures mais ce que vous connaissez
ce jeu le loup le loup garou on en avait
parlé on avait fait un loup garou enfin
on a parlé de ce loup garou grandeur
nature avec les villageois le loup garou
chacun un rôle hier voilà exactement ça
je traîne très amusant à jouer à
plusieurs et ensuite mercredi 24
novembre j'ai repéré un atelier à la
médiathèque le phare de maurepas un
atelier sur la thématique des jeux du
japon une sélection donc de plusieurs
jeux j'en cite quelques-uns king of
tokyo sushi go annabi je ne connais pas
personnellement mais du coup ça me donne
bien envie d'essayer et comme chaque
semaine vos suggestions aussi pour la
semaine d'après le week-end prochain ça
permet de prévoir un petit peu de place
aussi dans son menu et pour commencer
une exposition originale haute en
couleurs carrément oui vous faites bien
de le dire grégory haute en couleurs
parce que c'est vraiment ce qui
caractérise les peintures d'andré derain
peintres du xxème siècle né dans le coin
à chatou il est à chambourcy à
chambourcy part d'une messe vous en son
honneur l'exposition a donc lieu là bas
jusqu'au 28 novembre
la particularité c'est que ce ne sont
pas les peintures qui sont exposées mais
les affiches de nombreuses expositions
d'andré derain à travers le monde d'où
le titre de rein et andré derain
s'affiche parmi les affiches celle des
expositions internationales à londres
tokyo ferrari ou encore national au
centre pompidou au musée moderne de
paris ou encore de 3 l'exposition est
gratuite et accessible du mardi au
dimanche de 14h30 à 18h et s'éteint dans
la commune de chambourcy c'est bien de
douche et l'hébreu voilà je me moque de
vous mais ça m'arrive aussi des corps
chez certains mots alors on prend un peu
d'avancé sur noël pour terminer et on
débute ses courses carrément pour les
cadeaux exactement en dessert cette
semaine donc la foire aux jouets du
centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux dimanche prochain
le 28 novembre venait dégoter des
petites trouvailles perdu au fin fond
des greniers de 40 exposants avec un
petit plus solidaire écoutez denis vers
chef coordinateur événementielle du
centre par téléphone on a un partenariat
aussi avec le secours populaire français
qui viendra tenir un stand pour
récupérer effectivement ce que les gens
ont envie de donner qui n'ont pas réussi
à vendre et puis on a un partenariat
avec une école aussi l'école du lac
nicole alimentaire qui va faire un peu
de pub pour notre
pour notre événement et qui va aussi
collecté par le biais de son école des
jeux et des jouets une brocante spéciale
jouer donc l'occasion rêvée pour
débusquer de jolis cadeaux de noël
grégorini j'ai une question ce que vous
avez déjà écrit votre lettre au père
noël je les prépare elle est sur ma
table de chevet mais j'attends la poster
quand même vous avez été sages imaginer
voir quelques cadeaux jeudi j'hésite
encore entre quelques cadeaux on espère
que vous aurez tous vos cadeaux merci
bixente pour cette sélection et c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission se
retrouve bien sûr vendredi prochain pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 wickens tv
78 qui revient elle dès lundi avec vous
le journal de la rédaction pour
connaître l'actualité et ce qui se passe
autour de chez vous et d'ici là passez
un très bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]